- My question to you is
have you ever said something
to your kid that you
later wish that you hadn't
because they repeated it?
And then how do you get
your kids to understand
that sometimes, things that
are said in the household
need to stay in the household?
(laughter)
- Oh God.
When you know that answer,
let me know.
- Yeah, let us know.
- I'm going to be honest.
I told my, I just thought of this.
I thought I don't really
have anything for that.
And then I, my daughter became obsessed
when she was like four years
old about where she came from.
And I was like, "Well,"
I was like, "You were."
And then she started
being nervous about death.
And I was like, what is happening?
She was at four.
I feel like that didn't happen
like 10 for me, but whatever.
But anyway, she's advanced
and she was talking about
death and other things
and I want her to feel,
good about not dying
or anything like that.
And then also, "Well,
you were part of Mommy."
And then, you know, "So
you'll always have me.
"So even if Mommy dies, I'm,
"you were a part of me, you
were in Mommy's tummy actually.
"So like, you are always a part of me.
"And like, so that'll never go away.
"You're from my body.
"So like you carry Mommy on.
"So, you know, in a sense,
Mommy will never die with you
"'cause I'm a part of you."
And then she took that as in,
any woman in the world
regardless of you have a stomach or not,
walks up to and goes, "So
you have a baby in there?"
- Oh yeah.
- [Kelly] And just
doesn't matter who it is
and just is very excited that,
"Don't worry.
"If you die, she's still
gonna carry you on."
Like, it's still, and
it's like, you missed the,
we shouldn't tell people
that they're pregnant.
That's another one you should.
Yeah, that happened. A lot.
- You know what?
My four year old was obsessed with death.
Both of our kids were
obsessed with death and they,
when you're trying to explain
it, you've got to simplify it
because it's too much for them to handle.
So we had to explain that
Grandpa Greg had died
and was no longer with us.
And then they were like, "Why?"
And we're like, "'Cause he
ate too many cheeseburgers."
(laughing)
Because you can't,
if you go down the list
of ailments he had,
he'd be be there.
They'd be lose focus.
So then like every time we go somewhere,
they call them Dead Grandpa Greg.
And we feel like that's--
(laughing)
- Oh my God!
- And you know, we're too--
- Dead Grandpa Greg.
- It's accurate.
They're not wrong.
- Cheeseburgers.
- He had an appetite for a lot of things.
- Oh my gosh!
- My kids know that
there's no baby in here
but they'll come when I'm
wearing my relaxing pants,
my loose evening pants and
go, "There's a baby in there."
- Oh my God.
- Gosh.
- It's a food baby.
It's not--
- First of all,
can we talk that you just said
loose, relaxing, what did you call them?
Your loose, evening comfy pants?
(all laughing)
I love that!
My loose evening pants.
So it's like, I love you.
Your house is fancy.
- She has a very fancy name for 'em.
- I know!
(overlapping chatter)
- My Lululemon's that I don't do yoga in.